war what is it good for our experiences
of recent years of left us very wary of
foreign interventions but do we
sometimes have a moral responsibility to
intervene or is the moral course for us
to stand by and out of conflict or is
the morality irrelevant in all of these
decisions
I think there is a risk that we draw the
conclusion from the disastrous
consequences of some recent
interventions that we therefore decide
that no such intervention can ever work
and I think that would be an erroneous
conclusion to draw I think there are
circumstances in which it makes sense
because this is unfortunately the only
resort to intervene with some form of
military equipment and yet we are in a
position now where that argument is very
difficult to prosecute because we are in
the shadow of such horrendous examples
so to draw an overarching conclusion
from those examples where I think be in
error and when I say that I don't think
we're just flying blind we've got a huge
scholarly tradition behind us which can
guide us in trying to assess the
circumstances for intervention or not
the Just War tradition is deep and
scholarly and has three two parts
firstly there must be a Just Cause and
secondly war must be conducted according
to just criteria there's also a movement
to add a third part which is justice in
the post-war reconstruction but that's
not the ancient discipline it starts
with Cicero but one of the day offices
it goes through the central Olga's teens
and comes to a real fruition with Thomas
Aquinas and there is a very strong
argument that there has to be just a
purpose and we can argue about what that
entails and secondly then the conduct of
the war must itself follow arguments of
procedural justice and the case against
interventions like Iraq is that it could
not follow those precepts there is
perfectly good reason why those that
intervention did not work if you look at
Tony Blair's Chicago speech which is
essentially attempt to update Aquinas it
wasn't advertised as such but that's in
effect what it does the fifth criteria
of intervention in that speech is that
the intervention should have a
reasonable hope of practical effect
absolutely perfectly reasonable to say
there was no prospect of that
in that in the case of that intervention
therefore it should have fallen foul of
his own precepts and the there's a
brilliant remark somebody once made of
neoconservatism is there the problem
with it is it's not conservative enough
and the Just War theory is a very
conservative thesis but it does leave
open the prospect that if there is no
other option in the case for example of
a genocide or a war to the last for
civilization that military involvement
has to be kept in reserve for fear that
there is nothing else if we get to the
position where we don't allow that in
any circumstances at all then we are
potentially at times in peril
I don't think we can really say we're
reluctant to intervene when this country
is involved in a whole number of
interventions and has been over recent
years if you look in the last 15 years
which is where we've had the war on
terror or the it changes its name but
that it was started off as the war on
terror maybe it changed its name because
it was clearly not doing what it sought
to sort to achieve but if you look at
those interventions I would argue in
Afghanistan in Iraq in Libya where we're
now talking about going back into war
again that all of these have actually
made the situation worse that the people
of Afghanistan are fleeing as refugees
from war which is still continuing after
all those years as all the people of
Iraq and Syria so it seems to me I'm not
a pacifist I'm not somebody who says
totally that war is wrong I was brought
up by parents who were involved in the
Second World War and who suffered in the
Second World War in all sorts of ways so
I and I know that people sometimes have
very strong motivations for going to war
but there has to be in modern time there
has to be a reason for doing it which
isn't just about the strategic interest
of the West and isn't just about
supporting some governments and not
others if you look at the consequences
of war they are absolutely appalling and
therefore there has to be a very very
high bar that needs to be crossed before
you can possibly do it if you look at
the refugees today if you look at the
people in Fallujah today and will ever
sign you are all know for this these
people in Fallujah has suffered now
since 2004 with war occupation siege and
are still suffering as a consequence I
believe that the growth of Isis actually
developed as part of the occupation of
Iraq if you look at where the Isis
leaders came from they met in a prison
in in southern Iraq under the under the
occupation and I hesitate to bring up
the Chilcott report which is going to
report in a month after all these years
but if you look at what Eliza Manning
Buller the head of mi5 said for example
she told the government that it would
make the threat of terror
much much greater and this is the
situation we're in I also think when
we're talking about morality of all we
should also talk about the morality of
people who oppose Wars and today of all
days when we I hope all of us mourning
the death of Muhammad Ali we should
remember that he was one of a generation
who who fought and sacrificed to oppose
war in Vietnam now I was a teenager in
those years and I remember how much
everybody told us that war was justified
how much it was about fighting communism
how much the people of Vietnam would
appreciate the liberation we know now I
don't know how the other panelists feel
about Vietnam but probably few people
now would defend that war as a just war
or as a war that we should be involved
in so let's look at the people who stand
up against war and who say these things
are wrong who have a moral opposition to
it and who sacrifice very very often in
my view the world would be a much better
place if they were listened to rather
than to the government's and the
military who take us into so many wars
we've created for ourselves a false
dichotomy I mean we've heard about two
wars both which absolutely were
contested at the moment of their
initiation and through their conduct
Iraq and Vietnam and what I think in my
view we've done we've created a on the
one hand the idea that war should
unequivocally be necessary and the polar
opposite of that is always presented as
a war of choice and this seems to me a
totally unhelpful way of looking at
these problems the war of necessity
takes us back to the idea of the second
world war a war where it would seem we
had no choice where there was an
existential conflict and it's from that
that we have a UN Security Council sorry
we have a UN Charter which says you know
the only war that is genuinely
legitimate is the war of national
self-defense and the paradox in that is
that the only war that a state is
individually entitled to engage in in
terms of international law is
essentially a very very big one you know
there's no option there for a more
limited war which is the sort of
conflicts we're talking about there is
no no capacity for what we've come to
call a war of choice but that is exactly
it seems to me where we trip ourselves
up because as is absolutely rightly been
said the barrier for going to war needs
to be very high he needs to be seen to
be unequivocally necessary for it to be
warranted to take up arms whether that's
a moral necessity or a national interest
necessity either way there needs to be
an unequivocal necessity and once we
once we therefore have made that
decision then we need to recognize that
the commitment is equivalent to being a
to Neptune to necessity clouds of its
mind I perhaps hesitate to mention you
had situation Mohammed Ali I should
hesitate to mention clouds it's when
we're talking about war but clouds of
it's argued that war actually begins
with defense and not with attack if you
invade another country then actually the
other side can simply accept that
invasion there is no necessary
resistance there's no necessary response
so the paradox is that the the apparent
aggressor is not the cause of war it is
actually the defender that is the
of war and this isn't just splitting
splitting words because the choice in
other words lies as much in the
necessity the decision to fight as it
lies in the decision to initiate the war
in the first place so so my case
essentially is that we should rid
ourselves of this distinction and simply
recognize that war is very serious
business the challenge we now have
following out of the Chicago speech of
1999 is that the UN has adopted
alongside that principle of national
self-defense a wider principle which is
the responsibility to protect it cannot
be implemented without a UN Security
Council resolution which is why it
hasn't been implemented in the case of
the Syrians and the faith that they are
all undergoing but it does seem to be
extraordinary in the current context
that we've become so bound up in the
consequences of our own Wars in
particularly of Iraq and Afghanistan
that we find ourselves inhibited in the
ways in which we behave when there is a
genuinely humanitarian arguments from
profoundly pressing moral arguments for
engagement
[Applause]